let's talk about being here at the
Chinese Theater where Maryland would
come and dream and try to put her hands
and feet in these things how cool is it
to happen I'm wondering if we were going
to have her thing but no because I think
this was just here with a quote of her
where she used to put her feet here and
that's amazing pretty iconic right it's
incredible yeah we're here now what um
talk to me a little bit about your
transformation what what kind of time
did you spend in the chair what was that
like for you yeah that was quite a quite
a journey every day it was about three
hours to get ready every morning we have
an incredible crew of you know my my
hair and makeup team and then Jennifer
our costume designer was incredible too
we have over I don't know more than 100
wardrobe changes in the movie and
they're all so beautiful and iconic and
everything you know every detail is just
you know perfect
Marilyn Monroe
early Monroe I really remember
I can't face doing another scene with
Marilyn Monroe it was really amazing
it's such a uh you know big movie like I
mean it's we it's it covers 36 years so
um
that process of you know aging and you
know them very iconic looks or
Recreations of films that she did every
day when we achieved that look and we
looked in the mirror and you know we we
knew we got it was like yeah really
really beautiful yeah let's talk about
the standing ovation a 14-minute
standing ovation at Venice I mean
congratulations how do people even clap
that long I mean that must make you feel
extraordinary well how does it feel to
have your performance I only went for 10
minutes standing away
no I'm kidding it was it was truly
magical I didn't I you know it was such
a Venice is so wonderful and so many
incredible actors and legends have been
there and then all of the sudden you're
you know showing this movie after so
long and so much expectation and you get
that you know feedback and it's truly
magical and incredible and it's just
more than you can imagine and for 10
minutes it was
um it was unbelievable I didn't know
what to do with myself and everybody and
you know it gets very emotional because
it's a
is is the reaction you you hope for yeah
but when it happens and it's like you
know it's a lot it's yeah it is so well
deserved I mean the move the movie
really it just it takes you to another
place it is we all learn something about
Maryland we never knew
um talk a little bit about having uh
Brad Pitt and plan B behind you backing
you as a leading lady does that must
feel good I mean uh Plan B have been
behind this film for many years
probably you know I think now it's 14
years since Andrew have been trying to
make this film and plan B and Brad have
been very very supportive I don't think
we will be here today without them
they've been very pushing towards you
know what Andrew wanted and you know to
to protect him and his his version and
his vision for this film and yeah
they're incredible partners
[Music]